you're not entitled to anything you
don't necessarily deserve anything all
you have control over is how you direct
your attention and how you comport
yourself what are the actions that
you're taking how you're responding to
the world around you and when you drill
that down into the tiniest little things
that you're doing every single day and
try to repeat that with just rigorous
Relentless um
consistency that is how you move
mountains that's how you build mountains
that's how you change your life and that
is not something that's going to trend
on Twitter it's not sexy there's nothing
sexy about it it sucks and I
wish it wasn't that way and throughout
all of my reinventions and the changes
that I've made in my life I didn't do
them willingly I did them because I was
in so much pain that I was boxed
into a corner and felt like the only way
out was through